first a huge thanks to the people at
surf shark for sponsoring this video
what
is surf shark everybody great question
surf shark is a vpn vpn as you know
stands for
very personal network and it is a vpn
that basically allows you to put your
tablet down
anywhere in the world and surf the
internet
anywhere in the world you understand
what i'm saying so say
you were here in the states and you
wanted to watch the uk
netflix hey chap we're in the uk now
or whatever or maybe you wanted to watch
netflix from australia or you might see
i'm in australia watching netflix
something like that you know how good my
accents are not only that guys surf
shark bypasses censorship so say you
wanted to watch
what you know one of those special
videos from germany
i'm sure you could do that also surf
shark also allows you to put
their app on any device you got come on
guys this is an amazing product
one you need to hop on right now and
guess what i've got a deal for you use
my code
josh wolf all caps no space you get 84
off they had offered 82 off and i was
like you know what my people need
more than 82. they need 84. not only
that you're gonna get four
months free on top of that you don't
like it a 30-day
money-back guarantee so how about it
everybody the link is in the description
below
right where i'm fingering you and
remember josh wolf
all caps let's get some have fun on surf
shark and enjoy
this video later
i used to live in southern california
and when we had very little money
one of my favorite things to do with the
kids is i would take them for a day trip
to mexico one at a time
and because you could go and it was an
adventure you go down 50 bucks you could
eat lunch you could get some
a couple of knick-knacks and drive back
up super cool right
so it's his first time down and he is
pinned on 10. he's [ __ ]
so excited ha to be there right
and we get there and he turns to me
we're there for about half an hour and
he goes
dad i love mexico
everybody here is so smart and i was
like
i said what makes you say that man he
goes
they all know how to speak spanish and i
was like oh my god
i was like all right come here you dumb
[ __ ] all right
you're going to live with me till you're
40 aren't you buddy all right okay
so we were there for like another hour
and he decided he could speak spanish
because to him it sounded like this
i said do not speak the spanish
and he goes no i know how to speak it i
don't know you don't
we go to a restaurant waiter drops two
menus and he looks at me and he goes
what can i get you
and i said i would love uh medela please
and he said absolutely and he looks at
my son and in english
everybody he says to my son what can i
get for you young sir
my son's looking at the menu and he goes
[Music]
the waiter is being polite so he goes
excuse me and my son louder goes
like the waiter was the [ __ ] dummy
you know what i mean
like you didn't hear me right
and he goes mexican coke and the guy
walks away and i was like
jacob i go what did i tell you man i
said do not speak to spanish
and he goes i know how to speak it i go
no you don't
and he looks at me and he goes he took
my order
so i said i don't give a [ __ ] what he
did
i don't know if you know this and i know
you don't but you're insulting their
culture and their heritage and their
history and their language
all at once i know you don't mean to man
but you are
so i'm going to tell you right now under
no circumstance are you to speak to
spanish do you understand me
and he goes yes dad and we eat our lunch
but he's still sulking anybody who has
kids knows you reprimanded one time
they're done for the day you know so
he's sulking he's like i just want to go
home okay
so he goes can i sleep in the back seat
in the right home i go yeah and we get
up to the border
and the border patrol guy goes to me he
said you got an id and i said yeah
and he grabs it he goes you get a birth
certificate for the kid
i said no i said why do i need a birth
certificate for my kid and he goes
well i got to make sure every child who
leaves mexico isn't mexican how do i
know he's not mexican and i was like
[Applause]
[Music]
so i said jacob
speak the spanish my man popped his head
up from the back seat like this
the guy just looks at him and he looks
at me and he was like have a great day
[Applause]
we're driving out of mexico for like 15
minutes and he hasn't said a word but
the windows down you know what i mean
the window's down and i just hear mumble
under his breath
i told you i knew how to speak spanish
like a dick
[Music]
[Music]
you